i'm certain i've mentioned this before
but when i was working at t-mobile
this anytime i hear a harp i think of
this story and it's like
it's so [ __ ] depressing but it's
funny for me
and everyone else because we're not this
person but uh
i was working at t-mobile this person
comes in to get
her minutes re-upped because she just
had like a prepaid
uh card and i'm reloading her card
and uh i was like
there was like a art school nearby and i
was like oh yeah you go to school and
she's like yeah
i just graduated actually i was like oh
that's dope like uh what'd you major in
she goes harp i'm like wait what
she's like yeah i am i um i'm a heart
player
so i got a degree in harp i just didn't
know that was possible i was like oh
that's cool so like what she's like
she's like yeah it's kind of scary
because
i don't really know what i'm supposed to
do now she was so
deadpan about it and i was just like
what was her name do you remember
no [ __ ] no was it helen helen
ah nice no no no no no it's not
it's not i i will you know i'm man
enough to admit this is not
i'm not trying to get you here okay i
know that okay no
this is just there was a there was i
listened to how i built this of some
woman that started i think she started
this
sunscreen company what the [ __ ] is it
called
oh it's like they were the first ones to
do sunscreen that you were supposed to
put on like every single day
okay sephora you know bought up to all
their inventory they like
you know they're worth like millions and
millions of dollars now but she started
as a harpist that's how she made her
money she
and she like would call herself no maybe
it was holly holly the harpist
and would like go to nice restaurants
and like give them her business card
just hoping that she would get business
that way and she did she
made all of her money in the first like
five years just by going
and playing the harp at like dinner
parties and stuff like that let me
uh holly the harp no
uh this woman is blonde
no how hard would that like how sick
would it be to get a harpist for a party
though
oh yeah no just like even like a turn-up
party like a birthday or something like
that
well that that does happen that's the
[ __ ] you always saw in like cartoons and
stuff
where you know like there's a heart
player or i feel like in old movies
heart players yeah that's that's you
know
i mean hard player was the aux cord of
like what 1800
yeah that's true that's very true yeah
that was like going up to them can you
play the whisper song
yes by the yin yang twins
ping ping hey there little
i don't know what they say saying like
in 1800
can you play the whisper song by michael
blubley
[Laughter]
boobley dude how sick of a last name is
that
oh my god oh my god you sound like big
sean there for a second
oh my god oh my god zen the [ __ ] out
but yeah i just have to have to
punctuate that story with that girl just
laying that on me and then just sitting
in the chair while i reloaded her
prepaid minutes
and not really saying much else and i
was just like well
good luck have a good life i said
something to the fact that i was like oh
maybe you could like i don't know like
drop in on studio sessions and
that's what i was thinking what if we
got a harpist to come in and just record
some
crazy loops like can we make a whole
album that's just
harp trap beats i mean
[ __ ] trap beats what if it's just
rapping over harp
with no no drums no drums
it's the hardest wedding songs of all
time yeah we have a tap tempo
very softly internally and that's how we
stay on wow
what man look what does harp i can't
i guess the only time i think of a harp
is like game show [ __ ] it's like
or like turn the page type effect no
there's a there's a
um oh there's a tick tock sound that's
that's someone playing the harp
and it's very like emotional it makes
you think like something like you're
about to say something super
deep and and um uh what's the word i'm
looking for i can never
and just
whenever i'm listening to my own voice
through the headphones
something shorts out in my brain i don't
have that like circuit
oh okay so you just like get caught up
in what you just said yeah i just can't
think of things well i just i just like
so much i think
i just googled harp type beat so i'm
going to play i'm going to play the
second one
oh my god what's this mcconaughey video
you sent oh it's going to be good we're
going to play the
video okay okay hold on wait this is
just free
this beat free yeah this beat is free
yeah okay wait here we go ready play it
yeah let's go
oh what are you what are you feeling
right now i'm feeling
rainforest these are greg's beats
g-r-x-g great
oh
oh this kind of fire oh
[Music]
this is hard okay
just watch the drums be complete trash
it looks like game of thrones type beat
yeah i don't know about this i love it
[Music]
this is like chris brown type [ __ ]
[Music]
this is cool man we can do um
we can do a harp type beat
and then we could do a whole music video
and [ __ ]
uh armor
[Laughter]
post already did that [ __ ] oh yeah he
did that [ __ ] but we could also like fly
to new zealand and like
get it in the mountains oh i can
actually use the game of thrones set
like have this right
and we can dre we can act we can just
like [ __ ]
completely humiliate ourselves and dress
like
frodo and whoever whatever his boy is i
don't know
yep zether yep
and we just the whole music video is us
going to burn the ring but it's like
crazy vfx
like it's like a two million dollar
music video
that'd be fun just in vfx that's not
even the total budget
yeah it's like a five million dollar
video i would i'm in
i'm [ __ ] in for it
you